je n'étais pas toujours facile de demain
mais non c'est pareil c'est à dire
d'attendre que la boîte c'est mon petit
tu m'expliques c'est un programme qui
est très
intéressant c'est dire qu'on s'amuse on
passe un bon moment à la fois une partie
d'une pièce de théâtre qui dure une demi
heure c'est le rythme et on n'a pas le
temps de s'ennuyer on voit un panel de
plein de personnages et puis la formule
fait qu'après il ya une partie de débat
une partie interactive une partie où ils
ont droit de proposer des solutions la
thématique en elle même c'est une
thématique hyper actuelle que celui la
peur à l'école à la fois vous avez d'un
professeur et la fois les avis d'un
collégien voilà cette notion de j'ai pas
envie d'aller à l'école je me sens pas
bien dans cet environnement et c'est une
thématique bac était une commande au
départ ou qui est très actuel il
s'attend sur saisine sorte réussi dans
le fait du
corps insee
c'est la professeure de français
d'arthur elle est dans un moment de
stress assez intense où elle a
l'impression que les gens se liguent
contre elle que la moindre chose est une
montagne elle a du mal
à prendre un peu de distance à respirer
et puis un premier poste où le seul
objectif c'est d'éviter les coûts
supprimant
des élèves qui comprennent pas ce qu'ils
ont à apprendre jours arthur qui est un
jeune collégien en 4e et en 3e je vois
un jeune
un élève perturbateur de zep un cpe
rapidement et le perd un parent d'élève
je crois que ça fait 4 qui se baladent
sur une pièce de 35 heures on est
comédien donc le but de la pièce c2c de
pouvoir parler plus facilement des
personnages de leurs problématiques
parce qu'ils viennent de le voir que
c'est encore frais qu'eux on essaye dans
l'écriture de coller au maximum à la
réalité on essaie de cash en disant on
n'est pas fait pas d'eux
on évite la mièvrerie et mine de rien on
évite aussi la caricature c'est tout il
s'agit pas de montrer quelque chose de
trop et john s il faut que les gens
s'identifient il faut qu'ils puissent
bien ouais j'ai quand même des coups
très bien qu'on fait du mois qu'on
menace c'est de continuer ou on est à 2
voire du brevet